avant tout le monde mais le vétérinaire
c'était le plus gentil des
professionnels et être comme lui le si
ce que je voulais faire quand j'allais
est grande
je m'appelle céline leur te et je suis
vétérinaire c'est un engagement plus
profond de moi une partie de mon
identité et pour ce faire griffer uriné
dessus qui mordre voir ce qu'on voit ben
sentir ce qu'on sent ça prend la
vocation et cinq ans université de
montréal puis deux ans sur le terrain
pour commencer à se sentir le docteur de
toutes les espèces bon apport les
humains peut encore j'ai l'impression
les soigner un petit peu d'ailleurs il y
en a plusieurs qui me le demandent
non non vous n'êtes pas assez pour lui
pis les humains c'est beaucoup trop
compliqué ça parce que le jpy de doigté
pour être vétérinaire faut être bon avec
les animaux et avec les humains parce
que c'est un humain qui décide pour un
animal selon à ses croyances son
expérience ses finances
c'est un client qui décide pour un
patient c'est une réalité totalement
unique et puis c'est celle de tous les
vétérinaires sur la terre aujourd'hui
vétérinaire rime avec cher l'argent
c'est la face cachée de notre engagement
autant je supportais plus de mettre des
animaux morts dans un sac poubelle comme
si je travaillais dans la mafia
autant je supporte plus que j'entends
sur les vétérinaires comme si notre
image et et flétrie chiffonné par
l'argent donc j'ai créé une housse
mortuaire pour protéger la dignité des
animaux puis je suis ici aujourd'hui
pour protéger la dignité des
vétérinaires pour vous montrer la face
cachée de notre profession
après vingt ans sur le plancher des
vaches je crois encore que c'est le plus
beau des métiers
alliant la science et les coeurs est là
pour les gens est là pour les animaux
c'est tellement beau mais c'est un
couteau à deux tranchants un sport
extrême où il faut sauter dans le vide
constamment faire des interventions sont
avoir pratiqué avant ouvrir un estomac
6-1 au secours d'une mâchoire enlever
une masse ou un hameçon d'un cochon ou
d'un chaton de foule vers avoir le trac
l'adrénaline chômage cowan céline des
êtres en souffrance ont besoin de toi
ici et maintenant
comme eux tu dois être dans le moment
présent prend sur toi qui met des gants
des pierres en passant complètement la
vessie d'un shih tzu première sisto
tommy ou 20 août abdomen c'est par ici
heurter par l'assassin du liquide
contamine l'abdomen dont je fasse je
m'ennuie de ma mère j'aurai deux
courtiers immobiliers c'est ma dernière
par césarienne d'accord je vais en faire
une de plus une cocasse et faut imputer
elle c'est pas un travail c'est une
mission
mais c'est tellement cher le vétérinaire
pourtant les vétérans soutiennent la
pyramide des professionnels de la santé
avec les salaires les plus bas
ça nous vaut on vit très bien avec ça
lisse faire dire qu'on est là pour
l'argent c'est vraiment décourageant
parce que c'est une profession qui est
basé sur une vocation on peut pas faire
semblant
au québec un vétérinaire gang le tiers
du salaire de médecin
environ 85 mille dollars l'infirmière
vétérinaire qu'on appelle technicienne
elle gagne en moyenne 19 $ 50 $
pas de prime pour les heures
supplémentaires pas de retraite dorée
c'est notre lumière dans la clinique
sans elle on est l'ombre de nous mêmes à
peu près le vide de sens sur un show de
mauvais poil analysé les taux sanguins
assisté en chirurgie à peu même
hypnotisé un choix c'est pas juste une
technicienne c'est un ange gardien
hyper compétent elle étudie trois ans
pour savoir presque tout faire dans la
clinique a pas soigner les clients ce je
m'en occupe
mais je vous rassure et là chez le
vétérinaire il ya pas de commission pour
99% d'entre eux jouent pas d'incitatif
pour vendre des traitements des
médicaments on n'est pas là pour vous
plus mais ça fait tellement du bien
quand on sait que la personne devant
nous et pau à commission on peut
respirer on n'est pas menacée
aujourd'hui l'animal est un membre à
part entière des fêtes de notre famille
mais la société pas là pour les aider à
les garder en santé en 2019 au québec et
à 40 9 points 6
pour cent du budget gouvernemental
globale qui étaient dépensés en santé
plutôt en maladie très peu de prévention
une visite à l'urgence que 762 $ à la
clinique vétérinaire c'est 100 à 150
dollars une journée d'hospitalisation
pour un humain si 3063 dollars à la
clinique vétérinaire c'est de 50 à 200
dollars puis on mange très bien
quand j'étais jeune diplômé fallu
apprivoiser la fpt l'aspect financier
qu'on m'avait caché il ya un show qui
mangent pas depuis deux semaines quitte
mmorpg le jésus tente une radiographie à
60 dollars ou un test sanguin 45 à
l'époque le jugeait pour un test sanguin
comme ce jeu pour voir si il faut tenir
la route
ça vaut la peine de le traiter puis
c'est ce qui est moins cher je reçois
les résultats tout est normal
comme j'ai appris dans un séminaire du
client j'ai une bonne nouvelle tout va
bien de vos organes vitaux
on peut continuer notre investigation
c'est pour ça que je veux savoir que ce
qui est mon choix quarante cinq piastres
sait toujours pas que c'est que mon
choix coudon tous vétérinaire alors
tourné que la petite fille ça marche pas
son affaire
ben oui je serai bien retourner dans le
cocon de la faculté murray pas plus
montré à diagnostiquer pour 45 pièces
alors il a fallu soit toujours sur la
couenne et puis garder son grand coeur
parce que ces animaux sont nos amis
parfois la seule personne à qui parler
et qu'on peut toucher les meilleurs pour
nous prendre pour commander tout le
monde veut le meilleur pour eux mais qui
veut payer le prix du meilleur
on dirait que eu un malentendu entre la
population les vétérinaires des années
tout le monde voulait les meilleurs
soins l'acer iconia frais dus au
numérique doit arrêter mais tout le
monde augustine il de vie puis les
vétérinaires sont allés de l'avant c'est
parce que vous vouliez les meilleurs
soins finalement par exemple un chèque
jamais eu de son inventeur de sa vie
letarte
les dents pie ix à mal la tête depuis
des années mais sa petite que ce faire
et tout le temps il ya pas mal de temps
il se plaint pas il pleure pour un
animal ça ne se plaint pas ça ne leur
peau j'ai à la veille de le faire
peindre sur le mur de ma salle de
consultation moi je le détecte
l'inconfort dans ses yeux je suis son
interprète souvent son avocat ce que je
veux c'est qu'ils aillent mieux
peu importe que vous avez fait ou ce que
vous avez pas fait on est là bon le soin
dentaire ça va coûter entre 500 et 1500
$ ça va changer sa vie puis la vôtre
aussi 1500 $ pour un animal c'est une
allure ben oui ça même beaucoup d'alluré
et c'était la moitié il ya 20 ans mais
ça a tellement évolué radio numérique
dentaires 45000 de leurs moniteurs
cardiaques 9000 $ anastasie locale et
générale
extraction chirurgicale avec 25000
dollars de matériel sans parler des
médicaments il y avait un temps le
j'arrachais les dents avec des pinces de
plombier dentiste une fraise à pédales
on n'avait pas de radio ont fait ce soit
à l'oeil ou à les odeurs je laisser
s'aguerrir sans recoudre ça allait bien
il y avait des complications maintenant
ça va tellement mieux
on offre tellement des meilleurs soins
quand je dis ou clients je vais revenir
dans 20 minutes avec les résultats du
test sanguin
ils me regardent ils sont incrédules
jeudi perd on n'est pas à l'hôpital ici
on est dans une clinique vétérinaire et
20 minutes c'est extraordinaire mais ça
coûte 1000 $ par mois pour louer
l'équipement un établissement
vétérinaire bien géré et génère environ
10 % du profit sur les recettes
ça veut dire que sur une facture de 500
$ il ya 50 dollar qui reste pour
renouveler le matériel puis acheter un
paquet de gomme au propriétaire vous
saviez pas les vétérinaires employés
savent pas non plus faut juste
s'expliquer demain ça va déjà mieux
pas de commission pour là pour l'argent
un matériel coûteux c'est comme si on
venait de drainer un abcès dans le coup
d'un matou j'adore c'est tellement
satisfaisant c'est parce que vous
manquez fait le juste travailler plus à
l'école pour pouvoir drainer des
exceptions les commentaires sur les
soins vétérinaires sont excellence accès
facile pas beaucoup d'attentes soins
empathique suivi à l'os et céline de la
clinique
oui est-ce que tu puisses est bien remis
de sa chirurgie la plaie est belle
entrecôte ya quoi que ce soit habillé
nous après son décès une carte de
condoléances ni par toute l'équipe
moi ça me fait du bien quand mon père
est décédé c'est des soins qui sont
extraordinaires faudrait juste pouvoir
avancer pour moins cher
peut-être parce que c'est des animaux
mais c'est pas possible financièrement
imaginez si on se mettait à négocier
quand on est chez le médecin je vais
l'essayer la semaine prochaine je vais
chez l'ophtalmo d'autoroute de solo coop
ou 3 / ou bien c'est quoi ton meilleur
prix moi j'ai pas besoin de factures ou
ma préférée c'est un docteur sous amis
les humains vous feriez ça gratuitement
il va mesurer et on n'est pas chez le
vétérinaire imaginez et ayant une bonne
nouvelle il ya l'assurance santé
une solution pour les animaux a imaginé
son n'avaient pas l'assurance maladie au
canada 1 % des animaux qui sont assurés
en suède 40 % et quand j'en ai eu j'ai
l'impression d'être libéré je peux enfin
joué à médecins et non un vétérinaire
avocats psychologues planificateur
financier ta-25 à 75 dollars par mois
pour avoir la paix d'esprit de donner
les meilleurs soins
sa pensée ce bien la quantité
d'assurance quant au petit façon ça
changerait rien parce qu'on évite et
binaire mais avant tout humain le
réservoir d'empathie des vétérans est
vraiment profonde mais y est pas sans
fond la détresse des vétérinaires est
palpable
les chiffres parlent les vétérinaires
s'enlève la vie deux à trois fois plus
que la population en général
la moitié de ceux qui passeront à l'arc
et le front avec la substance qu'on
utilise pour mettre fin aux souffrances
des animaux lorsque tout le monde devra
quitter la clinique
le vétérinaire va injecter tranquille
pour mettre fin à sa déception à sa
souffrance
j'ai encore appris hier soir qu'un
vétérinaire s'était enlevé la vie aux
etats unis
il faut que ça cesse le vétérinaire est
maintenant une espèce menacée qu'il faut
protéger et au carrefour de la vie de la
mort des animaux les humains
beaucoup de canadiens m'ont finesse de
records ces huit dans une journée où
environ 5000 dans ma carrière
un jour 3 au canadien en simultané une
dame avec son golden de 18 ans ayant
perdu son mari son entreprise son
autonomie avec lui dans l'autre salle
une mère avec le show de son fils qui
avait dû être internée dans une
troisième sol en même temps un père en
larmes avec le show de son fils le choc
que son fils avait trouvés dans les
poubelles avait accompagné ce dernier
dans sa maladie incurable jusqu'à son
dernier souffle la semaine dernière pour
ce dernier je n'ai pu retenir ma
compassion sa douleur être traversé mon
cerveau mais c'est beau je vis la vie du
début à la fin a par dessus tout journée
en clinique à jouer avec des chiots en
parlant de chiots un jour on m'a demandé
dans le tannat d'une portée de 6 prêt
pour l'adoption
parce que c'est un client qui décide
pour un patient je demande à mon patron
mario à l'époque ce que je t'ai obligé
de le faire je dois le faire mais tu le
fais pas vraiment fini dans le fossé
ça devrait le faire oui et je les fais
nous sommes là pour les bonnes raisons
que la confiance remplace la méfiance
c'est ce que je souhaite aujourd'hui nos
deux solitudes se rejoignent dans cet
amour des bêtes qui nous unit tous cas
de rester camper comme deux choses sur
leur territoire j'ai besoin de confiance
pour jouer ou cali matters faire la
meilleure recommandations adaptées à
chacun je vais prendre des risques
révélés tous mes secrets je veux donner
tout ce que j je veux que ça marche
vous êtes en sécurité je suis surveillé
par l'ordre des médecins vétérinaires
un jour je vois une chatte qui était
attaqué par un coyote ses plaies vont
pas bien je pourrai l'envoyer dans un
centre de référence dont est chez elle
qui on sait pas combien ça va coûter
parce que la confiance règne
jose soigner ses plaies avec du miel
s'était utilisé dans l'egypte ancienne
mais c'est pas classique ici ça pourrait
finir en poursuite
mais je sens que c'est ça qu'il faut que
je fasse la chatte guéri fabuleusement
bien je réalise mon rêve d'enfant j'ai
utilisé mon coeur ma tête mon intuition
put aller au front c'est tellement beau
c'est ma mission
mais j'aimerais que vous aimiez les
équipes vétérinaires comme je les aime
parce que je les connais de l'intérieur
je connais l'ampleur de leur vocation
puis les sacrifices qu'ils font si vous
voyez l'amour qu'ils mettent dans les
soins nous n'en serions pas là
je m'appelle c'est l'une de leurs deux
et je serai toujours fier d'être
vétérinaire et comme disait mon père
plus je connais les humains plus jamais
mon chien
[Applaudissements]